um hsc revision um this this little
four-step guide
is how i encourage you it's not just for
maths but there will be some
specific things that i'm going to talk
about here okay so where does this begin
uh you've got hsc past papers
right they're easily available does
anyone know where to get them
the nessa website right good so that's
the first thing i'd like you to jot down
now what i'm going to do real quickly is
uh and this is why i asked
if you have your laptop there to do this
with me okay just pull open your laptop
get a browser open
and let's just quickly do this because
there's most of it you can work out
yourself but some of it's not
not intuitive so rather than uh
walk you through how to navigate the
nesa website there's so much stuff on it
actually can be quite hard to find what
you need
the easiest way is just just google
nessa hsc
past papers that's that's going to give
you the the quickest way to get there
it's the top link right there okay hsc
exam
papers the way nessa has structured
their website is that all of the
subjects are all there
in the same page okay so as you scroll
down it's oops it just reloaded it's an
alphabetical list
now one of the things you need to be
aware of is your course of course
your course of course is called
mathematics advanced but
you guys are the first people to sit the
hsc for the mathematics advanced course
in the past this course was called does
anyone know
what it used to be mathematics full stop
that's it
not a very helpful name but that's what
it is so mathematics is the one you're
looking for
okay now what you'll see there is uh
many past years
worth of papers there's quite a few
there and we're gonna you know we'll
chew through them let's just have a look
at last year's
when you click on there there's two
important things you need to recognize
there's a paper itself
that you can download but equally
important some people are going to say
more important
there's also the marking guidelines
underneath that okay so you'll need both
of them
so you can go ahead and download these
in your own time
okay yeah well i'll just quickly show
you and maybe if you've got your um
if you've got your computer you can look
at them yourself multiple choice is what
it is
but then as you start to get into each
of the
questions in fact let's go to a later
one which has more marks associated with
it something more interesting
oh that'll do okay here we go so this is
a question where you've got to do some
geometry in a circle
um so you've got to do the cosine
there's some trigonometry right that's
the cosine rule i wonder if you
recognize it there
a b squared etc right so what they
provide you as a sample answer
there are many many different ways as
you guys know to answer a question
correctly
but this is just an example that yep
this is pretty much what we were hoping
for a perfect response okay you guys
have spent enough time
as stage six students knowing that we
look for those particular things in your
solution
one mark two marks three marks no half
marks in the hsc
uh this is just a guide though you
should know that okay um it says sample
answer
every hsc year and cohort they'll do it
a little bit differently
so it's not like you can say what i
obtain the length of the chord a b
that should always be the second mark
it's not always but this is a pretty
general guide
okay so coming back to your piece of
paper
and i'll return to the nesa website in a
second what i suggest you do is you make
a schedule
and you decide uh when am i going to do
papers right you if you
fail to plan you plan to fail right so
you might say okay every week i'm going
to do a paper
or every three days i'm going to you
know do some amount of time you'll see
me talk about that in more detail
later on okay or just save yourself
um i'll come to that under the next
point okay
um now it's really important to know
that your exam
it's on the 26th of october easy day for
me to remember because it's my mom's
birthday
now what that means is because today is
the 28th
of august i went and counted
that's 59 days to go now
59 days may sound to you like a lot of
time or not much depending on how much
work you know you've got ahead of you
okay 59 days let's think about this and
this comes to serene's question
if you go back to this website right
back one more page
2019 it goes all the way back to 2002.
that's 18 papers
each paper is three hours long so it's
54
hours worth of an exam so i'm not
suggesting that you do this but if you
did an
hour every day and this is what you did
you'd finish every single paper
on there in fact i'm going to give
reasons why by the end of this you
should definitely be doing these papers
in less
than three hours okay and we'll come
back to that in a second
so one of the most important things to
mention on this website though is that
as we just pointed out these are
the old course the old course so for
that reason i'm going to suggest
don't actually do one of these papers
today instead on your computer
instead of searching for what do we
search for nessa hsc past papers
what i'd like you to google is this nesa
mathematics advanced sample okay so
mathematical advance is your course it's
a new course
nessa has only released a single sample
examination for it it's the top link
right there when you go to it the reason
why this is important is
at least two reasons number one
structure totally different
okay see how you've got two sections
here there's section one that's multiple
choice
that's the same but then section two we
used to have this predictable
there's question 11. it's worth 15 marks
question 12 it's worth 15 marks that
used to be the way it was arranged
this is not arranged like that in
addition to that it just looks
physically different for example
let's just scroll to section 2. section
2 will look like this
and hopefully we've been preparing you
for this unlike old hsc papers
you will provide your answers on the
actual exam paper itself so there's all
these lines there okay and we've been
sort of
getting you in that rhythm but when you
look at all the past hsc exams before
this
there's just questions no space to write
you've got to do it on your own okay
so you want to get a sense of what this
structure is like and also the topics
that are in mathematics advanced
that weren't there before also the
topics that were there before
that aren't there now make sense so this
is where i'd like you to start after i
finish here that's where i would
encourage you all to go first okay
all right back to the piece of paper so
you got the papers now
right what are you going to do any
guesses what the first word is there
next to conditions
come on have a guess exam conditions
thank you very much or
as close as possible to exam
conditions now the most important thing
is that it's timed
so you've got three hours for the paper
okay three hours
is how much you should allow for
yourself to do a paper
but of course we all know it's actually
quite hard to
find to carve out three hours for
yourself where you're not disturbed at
all
and you can just knuckle down and do the
paper if you can't get three hours
then you'll have to do it in chunks but
please monitor it right you might get
out the paper
i'm doing the 2018 paper today um i went
from
10 a.m to 11 a.m i could only do an hour
and then i was like
i gotta go do whatever go to work xyz
okay
so please mark down i did an hour of
this i got two hours to go
okay that way you don't lose track of
what's going on that's what i mean by
monitored
chunks um if you can't do three hours do
it's better um
please oh yeah question questions
imagine you're just doing the exam
and this happens to me i i get stuck on
the question
kind of the answers and what the process
should be i will come to that exact
point in about
three dot points okay so uh second thing
clear out the desk right make sure it is
exactly like what you're going to be
doing on the actual hsc that means
you've got your um
your actual exam pack and your plastic
sleeve or whatever it is you're gonna
have your water there
no books no computer no nothing okay it
needs to be just like you're gonna
encounter
what's the next one what do you think
starts with a queue quiet
environment now i know we don't have 100
control
uh 100 control over how much sound is in
our environment but you got a lot of
control
um here's a really hard one it's hard
for me personally and i expect it's
going to be hard for several of you
but do it no music
now i say this of myself first i
actually prefer prefer
to work with music it's part like i i
screen
people out and all that kind of thing
and get in a rhythm why do you think i
suggest
you don't have music
number one in the exam you will not have
music so you better get used to
concentrating in the quiet of your own
mind okay but secondly and
more importantly um we've talked about
this before right
this thing in your brain that we call
working memory
um working memory it's made up of three
components
uh and this is well researched right um
the first component is what we call your
visual spatial sketch pad which is
exactly what it sounds like
that you can um you can picture
something in your mind maybe it's an
equation maybe it's a diagram
you hold it in your memory while you
think about it okay that's the first
piece
the second piece is something called the
phonological loop i'll come back to that
in a second
and then the last piece is what we call
the central executive it's
the fact that you're not just
remembering some stuff but you actually
manipulating
in your mind and the central executive
is what's doing that manipulation
now i said i would come back to this guy
in the middle here your phonological
loop is your memory
not for things you see but for things
you hear
right now when you're reading a question
you're engaging your phonological
loop you're like oh there's uh six
months and i'm doing it quarterly and
it's 4.2 percent
you're reading that all in your mind
right and sometimes you can even hear
your own voice doing that
now your phonological loop uh it's it's
limited just like everything else in
working memory
and music messes with that real bad even
if you don't feel like
it is especially music with lyrics um
even music without lyrics will still
mess with that but all music does
so i'm going to ask you to develop that
discipline like i said i
say this of myself as much as anyone but
when you're doing your
exams exam conditions new music
ishan's question was about uh i can't do
a question
i'm gonna reach for an answer that's a
very natural instinct
but in exam conditions can you do that
of course not okay so that's why
no consultation you need to be
disciplined on this three things that i
don't want you to consult
notes and in that i include your book or
or the internet or whatever
and please do not consult the answers
right i'll come back to that one in a
second
just as importantly you're sitting next
to someone maybe i actually encourage
people to study together if they can
but ironically study together
alone don't consult your peers when
you've got a question you're like
hey um how did you do this question like
have you already done question 11 tell
me how you did it right
here's why okay number one let's talk
about why you don't consult your answers
you look at a question you're like i
can't do it so you look at the answer
hopefully the answer rings a bell you're
like oh oh i remember how to do this oh
it's the um
it's the cosine rule or whatever it is
right you fool your brain into thinking
i know how to do this question because
you read the answer and it made sense
you don't know how to do that question
that's why you looked at it and didn't
know what to do
okay so you trick yourself by consulting
the answers quickly
and the other thing is the same with
peers right you're like oh now it makes
sense and then you
feel content and you move on okay your
brain does something different
when you have nothing to lean on and
you've just got to rely on yourself so
in this case you said don't check the
answers what if you kind of see
the process of how that question is done
not until the very end and you'll see
why in a second like we're not just
doing this to get a general sense of oh
that's helpful i've got an idea of that
you've actually got to know what you
can't do that's a very important process
of doing these papers okay
now importantly i said timed three hours
in total right
however you aren't doing an exam so if
you need more time
if you're like oh i hit the three hour
mark and i've still got
x number of questions to do my
recommendation to you is
keep going but record the total time
record the total time you did take
you're like oh it took me four hours
or it took me four and a half okay what
you want to do is get to that point
where you're starting to bring that down
and that will happen with practice you
will develop fluency like i've seen this
question before i don't need to think
hard
i will just go for it okay so that's um
a record for you to show how far you've
progressed
um i i started at four and a half hours
because it just took me ages to remember
and i'll bring it down to three
and we want to bring it past that as
well okay
so you finish a paper whether in one hit
or in multiple chunks
then you've got a review super super
important
now your instinct again will be like i
stopped myself from looking at the
solutions
now i'm done let's go there straight
away i encourage you not to
instead what i'd like you to do before
you reach for the solutions
is to make a record of the quality of
the attempts that you made as you went
through the paper
okay now what do i mean by quality okay
you've finished there's your there's
your finished set of answers in front of
you
you will already know there were some
questions you just didn't even try
we teachers call that a non-attempt
right you're like i had no
idea how to do this i didn't even know
where to begin so i skipped it
okay you need to know and so do we you
need to know
what questions you didn't even know
where to start on because obviously
you're going to want to work on those
right
make sense record what you had nine
attempts on
record what you would call a low
confidence answer right you're like
i gave it a go but i'm like do i think
this is right
i don't know i just gave it a shot okay
um your next level are the ones which
you're like yeah that was hard i call
these the difficult but doable questions
um even though it was difficult maybe
like oh i screwed it up i had to go back
and fix it up at least you can say i'm
pretty sure this is the right answer and
i hopefully i'm going to get
confirmation when i look at the
solutions
okay yeah say it again and then the last
one
is well i'm actually going to say rather
than confident i'm actually going to say
comfortable
because you're going to get to a point
where some questions you'd be like
i've seen this exact question before
they just changed the numbers on me
right i can do this question and not
only am i confident with it i feel
pretty good about it i feel comfortable
okay now when you do your first paper
you know
in about 10 minutes okay i'm going to
tell you right now there's going to be a
bunch of questions you're just not going
to know what to do because
the knowledge for that question you
learned so long ago
like 12 to 18 months or more you're like
i'm just stuck
okay don't feel bad that you did that
but maybe
if 20 of the paper the first one you do
is a non-attempt
let's try and make progress and reduce
that percentage yeah by the end of this
you want that to get to zero right you
at least want to put
something on the page for every question
right
and what you want to do is get to the
point where you have a higher and higher
percentage of questions
that you're comfortable with um ideally
i'd love you to say 100
but you certainly want to go from some
lower number up to a higher number
that's part of how you will measure
progress does that make sense
okay so that's how you're gonna
before you look at the solutions record
the quality attempts then
if possible if possible instead of
marking yourself
swap it with someone else okay someone
else is going to be marking a paper
you're going to like your paper why do
you think it's more helpful
for someone else to mark your paper
rather than you
we're generally kind to ourselves we're
like i was pretty close right
um max are you gonna say something
similar or different same
anyone else a different suggestion
have you ever come to a point where you
came back
uh from an exam and you've gotten a
question marked wrong
and you come to mrs lee's or me and
you're like but what i meant to say was
this
like what i was trying to do was this
what do we say to you when you say that
but you didn't show
it you didn't show it right i can't tell
that's what you meant
i can't mark your brain i have to mark
your paper
right now by getting someone else to
mark you force them to do that and a
question you thought
you'd done pretty well on they'll say no
you didn't cut it man like i didn't see
like from my brain which is outside of
you i couldn't objectively
prove that you understood this okay and
you will also benefit a lot by looking
at someone else's working you'd be like
oh
surely that's it this way that's clever
right so to do that you'll benefit a lot
if you can okay
then lastly it's been marked either by
you or someone else
please like always analyze your errors
and what that's going to do is it's
going to direct number one the revision
that you do
you'll go back to the homework that we
assigned on your calendar and you say ah
it's the trigonometry that's the stuff i
don't know how to do go find the
exercise
review it okay and also it'll direct the
questions that you ask us right
um please come and ask us for help
do not be content when you look at a
question you're like i got it wrong
my friend who marked it told me what to
do instead and i'm like oh okay i get it
now
don't stop there if you just know how to
answer that question you don't really
understand it you've got to go back for
the concept underneath the skill
okay on the um back side
of that page you'll see something
familiar this is a page we've given you
before right
this is what i encourage you to do when
you're analyzing your errors it's why
i've given you this framework many times
in the past okay
say it again did you leave one did i
leave one what
oh that's not what it's meant to be
anyway i'll come back to you in a second
okay
um there's one last thing you have to do
you found the papers you did them you
marked it you've reviewed what do you
think the last thing is
you need to reward yourself okay now
this is really important this is really
really really important
your brain has this thing we call the
dopamine center
right which is the heart of motivation
you will do things that are hard
if you know that it's worth it if
there's a payoff right we do this all
the time okay
you need to have some discipline here
you need to have perhaps something to
reward yourself that you can't easily
get yourself
because otherwise you'll just do it
you're like i think i think it's time to
treat myself right
it needs to be something maybe you give
someone like uh
some food you love or some time or
whatever it is but you should do this
you've achieved something three hours
the paper's not easy if you've done it
properly
give yourself a reward make sense